hey guys welcome to the Spate Waterland
Rugby World Cup preview show we've done
something like this before with Super
Rugby but now with the biggest
tournament in the world about to take
place over the next few months we had to
get amongst it and yes I have even
managed to get the lad surely from
surely talk sport
um to help me talk through all these
games and what's about to come he's even
heading over to France to pick up on the
atmosphere and get all the insights as
well whatever we need he's there for us
he is the true lad welcome surely yeah
cheers for having me here look when you
offered the gig I thought you know we
need someone on the ground so I'll take
that role on my shoulders fly over the
wife she wasn't sold so she decided to
come too so a little bit of carry-on
luggage there but it'll still be a great
trip when do you fly off uh Friday
morning heading over got a couple days
in nice before heading to Paris to get
amongst that first game oh mate so
you're going to be missing the wise home
finals I know that's going to be a huge
set sacrifice for you but doing it for
the cause yeah to be fair when the uh
when the draw came out rookie mistake
from me I forgot she was a 27 week
regular season this year obviously
redcliffe have come in the extra buy so
it blows it out normally that first
weekend of September is Grand Final week
so I thought I'd be here for the whole
of it but have spoken to the wife of the
lads are in the Grand Final I'm leaving
two days early going straight to Sydney
so I can't wait gotta ticket as well so
I'm ready to go
wow that's a huge cool seed but what
game would you be missing at the World
Cup uh I'll be missing that final pool
game yes I'll be flying straight the
wife will be flying back to Auckland
he'll be saying our goodbyes at Dubai
and I'll be heading over to Sydney
oh that is huge and what do you reckon
like obviously you're doing the one
warriors podcast at the moment if you
are listening you haven't checked that
out go have a listen to that surely at
his best talking to some of the great
warriors but have you found it have you
found this year with the world is
obviously what a year from the land oh
it's been crazy like obviously been
doing the podcast with them unofficially
for a couple years as well it's crazy
what wins do obviously people really
jump on board I feel like this up the
wires movement has created a massive
audience as well but yeah the boys are
going great guns they're getting the
wins and as a result people are showing
up so it's a pretty cool feeling at the
moment I feel like they've almost stolen
the Limelight off the All Blacks a bit
but look maybe that's our job to get the
boys back on yeah up the walls but also
up the a b so we will get straight into
um talking Rugby World Cup and I'm
guessing the best place to start is the
last round of warm-ups and we'll start
with the All Blacks vs South Africa not
a great lead-in game for the All Blacks
but I guess better now than in a few
weeks
yeah it was pretty disappointing wasn't
it obviously woke up Saturday morning I
love that time slot too that was great
rather than the Sunday because obviously
you know brought to you by Spates we
like having a couple Summits on a
Saturday night so rolled into this one
fresh but if here to say I thought I was
in a bit of a nightmare mate yeah no
good hey like even from the start like
they were under the pump heavily early
um South Africa just put them under all
sorts of pressure Camp right on their 22
and discipline was costly for the All
Blacks and they just couldn't really get
out of it yeah I think we saw that at
South African Ford pack really with a
chip on their shoulder like when we
played them back at Mount smart well
almost a month ago now probably it
looked like we had the start that every
team wants you know we came out the
gates firing then that second half they
kind of picked us back once they brought
on your Malcolm marks and Co and I think
from this game we kind of saw their best
forward pack right from the opening
whistle and geez they're a scary side
aren't they yeah they've got a massive
pack and pretty much two men massive
packs going the 7-1 split yeah very
unusual in rugby to go 7-1 split so they
brought their whole second pack on
pretty much barring one
um on about the 45 minutes so a complete
change of four packs and just both packs
are pretty much as damaging as each
other yeah it's crazy obviously our
loose Ford Trio probably isn't the
biggest going around but pound to pound
you back us you know Sam Kane Rd
Jacobson we really did miss Frizzell
just for that size Factor but they're
strong blokes like getting around Super
Rugby they dominate but once you Chuck
them up against the South African four
pack on their day you just notice that
difference the extra kind of 10 kilos
and a bit of height can make especially
at set peace time I thought I'd line out
that'll be worrying for Ryan like
obviously he's done a massive job coming
in and really kind of overturning the
way the four packs operating but I'd say
that they would have got the sprayer
Dome after that games and that sort of
goes on to the game I just felt it was
so stop start I felt like the referee
was into everything obviously a lot of
those decisions are fair but you can
literally call any breakdown a penalty
if you want so just trying to find that
flow a little bit better I feel like the
refs are going to play a massive part
hopefully not and hopefully the TMO can
stay out of it I'd love to see both
those tries awarded I feel like if the
ref has a concern with the try then he
can go up to the upstairs but I hate
seeing a TMO check everything over the
last four phases to make sure there
wasn't a knock on or a slight offside or
something because you're going to find
it pretty much every time I would have
loved to have seen that South African
try awarded and I would have loved to
have seen uh will Jordan's trial water
as well going back for the TMO checking
it just doesn't sit too well with me I
feel like you lose you lose the moments
of the game a hundred percent I think
like at half time I almost had to
decompress and I felt like it took
forever and then I think the sky team
mentioned that it was 60 odd minutes to
play 40 minutes of rugby like that's
really tough both as a fan and as a
player especially for the All Blacks I
feel like we play our best footy when
it's an Up Tempo game we're able to move
teams around the paddock and with those
dual pivots Richie and Bodhi we just
want to play eyes up and move the ball
into space and fatigue's a big factor
out of that so when it's so stop
starting and these big opposition packs
are getting time to rest just makes so
hard to get on the front foot so yeah I
feel like referees injuries all those
kind of things are going to play a
massive part in this world cup you just
really hope it doesn't determine who
wins the thing because we all want to
see some good running rugby I think
everyone around the world does so
hopefully that's the way it plays out
but yeah that was a tough tough watch
yeah and I think that is what most teams
are going to try and do Against All
Blacks like you said when they're when
they've got quick ball and they're
playing on top like they were at Mount
smart against South Africa the
difference between that compared to the
weekend when it was slow stop start
going set piece to set piece I think
that's the formula most teams will try
and beat the All Blacks with so I guess
it's about them coming up with a plan
when teams try and do that how they can
keep that Tempo on the game and make
sure they're playing with that freedom
and quick bull that they they sort of
need to find points for sure how much of
that weekend do you think because a few
people have brought it up like all
blacks just holding things back they
don't want to show their cards too much
like do you think that that played a big
factor do you think the lads were
holding back a lot of things or do you
just think South Africa were up for it
and wanted it a bit more yeah it's an
interesting one and it's the same as
like all sort of preseason games you
don't hold back your shapes and your
defensive structures and all that
because you need to sort of get the Reps
at those but you'd hold back potential
launch first phase moves that you've got
that you think you might score against
them
um I think you'd come up with obviously
a whole new lineup menu as well those
sort of things that you're changing more
often but the big nuts and bolts of your
game the the defense structures and the
attacking shape they'll all be the same
so there was a fair few concerns there
but they're all pretty easily fixed so
I'm still pretty confident heading into
the world cup with them to be if out if
you're saying who's going to win it I
think there's so many cases you can put
forward for all the other sides and
we'll get at the back end of this
podcast on who we think is going to win
and where it's all going to finish but
we'll move on to the next game with
which was Samoa vs Ireland now Samoa
they are going to be a team that are
going to be tough to beat in this
competition physical and got some talent
in that backline now too oh big time
look like Brian Lima was the tackling
coach the Irish were getting folded and
half left right and Cindy you sent me
that photo of uh Bundy arcade traps of
Doom the bloke shredded out of his mind
but I think geez no one wants to run
into that Samoan side that's natural
just power and muscle and I think we see
how good it is to have Lima sopawanga
there like we see the benefit of having
a world-class first five just to kind of
a cooler head with a lot of
international experience to steer around
this team he makes a massive difference
I thought during that pacific Nations
cup at them in Fiji kind of stole the
Limelight from Tonga who rocked up with
a really star-studded lineup so I'm
excited to see Samoa go about their work
and I I wouldn't be surprised if I think
their last pool games up against England
there could be a fair bit riding on that
one yeah that's going to be a massive
game hey obviously England have been
struggling they struggled against Fiji
in the weekend but I I do like what I
saw from Sama on the weekend obviously
um the great Coach Andrew Goodman who's
been on Woodland before he's he's
running a lot of their attack and I
could see a lot of their shape looking
really good and Ireland struggled with
it especially when they got some of
their big boys through the line and one
guy who impressed me was the fullback
Duncan now excuse my
um pronunciation of his last name but
who plays for too long but man he was
impressive from the back I liked a lot
of his game yeah you don't want to kick
and bold oh yeah he's pretty deadly and
like you need that in these levels you
need guys that are game Breakers but I
also have the fundamentals about their
game because so often kind of Samoa's
downfall has been they want to express
themselves but also not getting the
timing right in terms of the games like
often they're in these tussles the
game's in the balance and they'll just
try Razz it up but looks like they've
got that great balance of like strike
power they've got some nut truckers and
some hard workers in there and then they
got sappawanger to guide them around the
paddock so it's really exciting for the
odd I'd love to see them get out of the
pool it would just be a massive story
yeah how good would that be and and you
mentioned supawang I think you're you're
right his game driving ability has has
been something they've missed over the
years so his ability to step up and
guide that team around in big big games
is going to be crucial for them and
they've got the likes of Ben lamb still
to return onto a wang
um we've seen what he can do at Super
Rugby he's he's an incredible finish a
tough man to tackle so I mean the loose
four Trio man they've got talfur coming
off the bench and Steven Lua tour
they've got X Factor everywhere as well
so
um yeah wouldn't want to be playing
summer in the pool face to be fair no no
what did you make of Island because
obviously it wasn't their best side they
made quite a few changes but still you'd
expect them they hidden amongst the kind
of top two top three favorites do you
kind of expect them to look a little bit
more clinical than what they did yeah I
I did going into that game but um on
reflection I guess
um it wasn't the worst result over the
weekend they still managed to grind out
a good win and like you said it wasn't
their full strength side and I do think
there is a little bit bit of a depth gap
between their strongest side and their
their second string side and we saw that
sort of for Leinster
once they get back likes of Jamison
Gibson Park and Jonathan Sexton who will
be back pretty soon I think so once you
get a couple of key guys like that back
I think we'll see a different Island
team and I still see them as probably
the team to beat them in France along
with the All Blacks I think yeah it's
going to be it's going to be a hell of a
World Cup that's for sure but we'll get
to the next game England and Fiji we
knew Fiji could play we've loved Fiji
for ever since the drawer back in the
days haven't we good to see how bossy
back out there on the wing causing all
sorts of Havoc which we knew he would
two years ago but
um England man they're in all sorts of
trouble at the moment heaps of pressures
come on both work and the public seem to
be right into them yeah for sure I think
uh a friend of the show Nick Evans will
be glad he's not in that setup at the
moment because I'd say they're under the
pump right even Eddie Jones probably
feels like he's got a weight off his
shoulders with Aussie because people
almost didn't expect this from England
so they're up against it I love Fiji
mentioned before Pacific Nations cup I
thought they were real standouts and
I've been telling people that beat Wales
game one which kind of has me worried
now because they were going in underdogs
and now people standing expect us yeah
yeah it's it's all going but it's just
great to see Fiji again another side
that in the past looked like they maybe
lacked a bit of direction and big game
experience but now with the drawer I
think their introduction has been
massive um obviously you guys the
Crusaders went to Fiji this year and
they were able to claim that scalp like
things like that to your confidence just
knowing that you can beat these top tier
sides and then the amount of quality
players they have playing in Europe it's
almost like a home World Cup for a lot
of Their Stars so it's incredibly
exciting
um yeah England and turmoil but as an
all blacks fan you love to see it that's
probably the one team even Aussie but I
would love to see Panic so it's great
stuff yeah mate you mentioned them being
favorites they are now ranked the
highest out of their pool so they're
ranked higher than Wales Australia they
are the other favorites to finish top of
their pool which it was incredible if
you thought about that at the start of
last year but and they've done it and
they deserve it and one player who's
stood out for me is a months at 10.
someone I felt like has really stepped
up to International foot is running a
really good cutter guiding the team well
the likes of Raj Raja outside him who's
man what a beast that man is
um and they've got obviously Strike
weapons everywhere across the back line
so they've always they had that and it's
that 10 and lamani as well who I thought
it was one of the standouts in Super
Rugby
um the combination between Muntz and
lemani for me has been the difference
between Fiji this year and Fiji of
previous yeah that's a good call and I
saw when they announced the squad there
was a lot of kind of controversy over in
Fiji about no Ben volleyball because
because for so long he's been that tin
that pivot pulling the strings for them
but at the moment anyway it certainly
looks like that selection was justified
and how good would it just be for Fijian
rugby I can only imagine the scenes over
there on the weekend when they got that
historical one it would have been unreal
to be over and amongst the locals
because if there's a nation that loves
their footy you know all black South
Africa we all love our code but fijians
are right up there it's so different
over there it's so cool to see them so
succeed obviously we like you said we
lost them over there it was one of those
moments where you instantly gutted but
then you look around and you see what it
means to the whole of the um crowd and
the whole of the country and you just
sort of brings a bit of reality to it
and um you sort of appreciate what what
it means to them and um yeah if Fiji can
top their pool and go into a
quarterfinal or advance to a semi or a
final would be absolutely magical so
yeah I'm on the bandwagon
um to jump on I'd love to see a Fiji New
Zealand final that would be I don't know
how the drawers work actually I need to
work that out but it could be possible
yeah I think it is possible I think
they're on that other side that kind of
everyone was saying looked easier but
now with the teams kind of the Gap
closing on the rankings it looks easier
but those things are in for a heck of a
battle Yeah they are for sure and the
next game we've got to speak about is
Aussie and France
um France is far too good for Aussie um
Eddie like you said he's under the pump
um might not be as much as both work but
he's still heavily under the pump oh
Eddie Jones what a guy he's almost like
but just he's the entertainment Factor
the game's secondary like you just tune
in to see him what he's gonna dish up
during the week and he's trying all his
trucks you know he's trying to have a go
at reporters just to Chuck the attention
off the boys but it's not working he
even tried to bring an old mate sir
Steve but I think shag one up them you
know I think he went on Trojan Horse and
really threw a kid amongst the pigeons
and it resulted in a France 13 plus when
I was calling for the for the reverse
Knighthood and we unsure shag but now
after that shift I think we saw one of
them are great yeah one of the great
Trojan horses we double it now so yeah
man crazy but I think it was more France
they're a good football side rather than
Australia being really bad actually
thought Aussie were pretty alright in
patches it's just that the French are
genuine team no intimac but I think
people kind of thought that he him and
Dupont were just the keys to Victory but
they've got depth at 10 they've got
other kicking options and with Dupont
there there every bit of a chance mate
how good is that guy he is he is the
best player on the planet for me he is
freakish that one try where I think he
just dropped it on his bad foot for a
Crossfield kick at half back and it was
just pinpoint perfect like I'm lucky to
do that on the Good Foot mate I'll be
I'll be partying for weeks if I pulled
that off on my right leg let alone the
left so yeah he's another 10 and he's
one of the best tens almost so that's
such a luxury for them and that that
Ford pack can certainly roll up their
sleeves too so yeah everyone says
Ireland and France I definitely think
those are the two main threats South
Africa as well will get into that but
yeah the French at home or that first
game I'm so excited already yeah and I
can't believe you're going to be there
and what do you make of Aussie like you
mentioned they're better than you the
scoreline sort of suggested yeah I think
they are but I don't think they're good
enough to really kind of threaten these
top teams I I think
yeah they're good enough to beat some of
the lower ranked sides but yeah I can't
see them being a genuine Contender a lot
of people are saying that because of the
easier side of the draw they'll be there
or thereabouts come finals time I'm not
so convinced that I I still struggle
with some of these selections like no
Quaid Etc I don't know I'm a quake
Cooper fan I actually rate what he
brings to this side Off the Bench but
yeah for me they're kind of there but
not good enough to beat the good sides
what about yourself yeah I'm thinking
the same like I've seen patches of their
game and think man they've actually they
could they can play I feel like they're
backline they've got a nice back line
when their packs working I love Fraser
mcright I think he's a quality seven
karivi and you get the big Winger Mark
running with the offload and fin going
they've got some strike power all over
their backline
um and some of the attacking shapes
really nice as well but I just don't
feel like they've been consistent enough
and like you say when the pressure comes
on they have crumbled pretty much every
time so um it's going to be interesting
their pole obviously Wales Fiji Georgia
Portugal as well but those probably
first four are the other ones I don't
think they'll have an easy win against
any of them oh I'd love to see them not
make it
Aussie and England out in the pool oh
there we go
first yeah that would be unreal and the
other game Italy vs Japan
um a little bit more undercover game but
Italy pumped Japan I don't think um
Japan are the team they were four years
ago I feel like they've uh haven't quite
progressed like the other sides have so
it's a shame to see I loved watching
Japan and winding them home uh they were
home World Cup but looks like it's going
to be a bit more of a tougher year for
them this year yeah it is a shame
obviously like that was the kind of
fairy tale story of the last World Cup
and as a result the game over there saw
some massive growth but yeah I don't
know you just wonder like now that
they're no longer in Super Rugby do you
think that that's had an effect on their
quality of play as well because yeah I
know the timing's kind of ironic they
were in Super Rugby playing some great
code as a result now they've dropped out
I do think that that plays a part in it
quality competition each week against
like in New Zealand and Australia sites
that's an interesting point because
especially when we speak about Fiji as
well and how the growth of their game
even Samoa to an extent with Moana and
their the growth of their International
sides compared to Japan over the past
few years has been significant so it's
got It's got to have something to do
with it even if it's not this star
players it's the the rest of the guys in
behind who are learning about
professional rugby and when they're
given the opportunity at this level
they're they're ready to step up so
um yeah I think I think you make a valid
point there I think that's a big part of
it and what do you make of Italy are
they a chance in their pool obviously
they pump Japan but New Zealand and
France can't see them going close
against either them can you no I think
maybe if they were in that kind of pool
with Aussie and England you're those
teams like that then possibly I just
think New Zealand and France are going
to be a class above but in saying that
Italy they did beat Aussie last year and
we've seen them take some steps forward
so they're no longer that side that you
go up against and you think oh you know
70 80 nil give the lads a rest like I
think we're gonna have to respect them
for at least 40 minutes of that game to
kind of get a head start and put them
away before we roll the bench I think
they have come on and Leaps and Bounds
but they're not quite at that next tier
yet agree I don't think they can beat us
but if we lose that first game to France
um it'll be quite nervous times going
into that Italy game both teams having a
lot to play for playing for that second
spot
um yeah I think would be too good for
them but like you say they are capable
of an upset so
um yeah hopefully we get the job done in
that France one so it's an easy watch
for the rest of the pool games because
we will go through those pool
predictions now hey we'll go through
pool a which is obviously France New
Zealand Italy Uruguay and Namibia I
can't see Namibia all Uruguay posing
much of a threat those are the ones if
they do want to rest players those will
be the ones I'd imagine
um and then getting up for the two big
ones which will be France and it will be
Italy they will go full strength against
those guys 100 yeah I feel like well
every World Cup we take on Italy and we
take on Olivia like is that a is that a
given is that just mandatory when you
roll into World Cups All Blacks Italy
you know the uh the rest kind of fallen
from there but yeah I agree France and
the All Blacks hopefully all blacks in
one France and two so obviously that
first game you're with predicting the
All Blacks to to beat France yeah I am I
I think we'll get up for this one I
think the whole narrative around it is
kind of perfect now like you see it
cracks me up as New Zealand as a
sporting Nation you know a week ago two
weeks ago we were home and hoes winning
the World Cup this side ever comes
Saturday at midday it was the world was
ending Panic stations Galore everyone
was calling for fuzzy gone again it's
just chaos but I think we will beat the
French in the first game and then
everyone will get really carried away
again how about yourself do you reckon
we'll Rock up get the win or I hope so I
probably hope more than confidence I
think it's going to be a hell of a game
and I can almost see that being the
final again to be fair yeah it's going
to be a hell of a game I hopefully your
support being there can wind the boys
home
um I think yeah atmosphere is going to
be incredible French have a big pack
they would have saw the what the South
Africans did to the kiwis and but
they've obviously got the guys like to
pawn in the backs who can play Dante at
12.
um great players so it's going to be a
hell of a game I'm gonna I'm gonna come
with you um jump on the all black
prediction and
um say that they're going to finish top
but obviously not surprised at all if we
finish second and then that draw this is
where the pools come into play will be
playing either Ireland South Africa or
Scotland either way so whatever wherever
we finish it's going to be a hell of a
quarter final anyway yeah um Paul B
South Africa Ireland Scotland Tonga and
Romania what are you predicting here
who's your two that is a deadly poll
because I really like Scotland and about
a month ago I was doing some uh Futures
and I put them to beat South Africa
obviously after the weekend now I'm a
little more nervous because South Africa
looked really good but I like Scotland I
like what they're about with Finn
Russell at the 10 like he's one of my
favorite players to watch just because
he can walk for like 10 minutes and then
just turn something on like I wish I
could turn something on I've got the
walking in my game I don't have to turn
something on but it's just so fun to
watch so I I like the Scottish I hope
they can beat South Africa first up and
then an island could get out of that
pool that would be unreal but I I think
South Africa current Ireland will be the
two to advance but I wouldn't be
surprised if all those teams kind of
drop one game or the big three anyway
you're Scotland your Island you're South
Africa they kind of beat each other and
then it comes down to points
differential all that kind of jazz yeah
I wouldn't be surprised price if you get
the old Finn Russell look-alike tag over
there in France I reckon people will be
getting photos with you geez that's a
Dead Ringer right I'll claim that
absolutely uh obviously skill level
ability quite different maybe I should
buy like a Scotland Polo from the merch
shop and just really try and milk it you
know get on the field in the works
I reckon you're capable but yeah like
you say I've been loving the way
Scotland been playing
um thin out the back pulling the trigger
they've got some great backs some yeah
four to work hard and their D structure
is really nice so
um South Africa we saw what they can do
on the weekend they love the Test match
footy as well big pack box cake they
love that game and they have the backs
and talent that can score from anywhere
as well and obviously Island rate then
very highly I think Ireland would finish
first South Africa second and
unfortunately Scotland miss out even
though they're probably
the fifth best team in the world cup
don't even make the quarterfinals yeah
what's your thoughts on how far out they
do the draw like to me looking at these
pulls it is a bit of a shame now because
obviously things can change over the
course of a year or two would you like
to see them move it a little closer the
draw obviously it's all a logistical
type of thing but I feel like you could
still pull it together maybe a year out
rather than a couple years out yeah
whatever doesn't get in the way of the
logistics make it as close to the
tournament as possible where I can so
then you do have a really even split
you're not having pools so lopsided but
and saying that it's also brought a
whole new dimension to the competition
hasn't it you've got one incredibly
stacked pool with three teams who could
all go on and win the competition in one
pool and one is not even going to make
the quarterfinals so
um yeah there's a lot a lot of different
things to talk about with it as well so
um I know it's disappointing it would be
good to see the best teams make the
quarterfinals but it also brings a
little bit more excitement into the pool
place so a good Shout good shout uh Paul
C why Wales Australia Fiji Georgia
Portugal now we've spoken about this
Fiji and now the number one ranked side
in this pool followed by I think Wales
is it and then Australia yeah I think so
and then Georgia's just next in line
with them I haven't watched much of
Georgia to be honest over the last four
years but
um they've been knocking on the Six
Nations door for a while wanting a crack
they've been in Italy a few times they
can't play yeah they can play I haven't
watched much of their top side but I've
watched quite a lot of their under 20s
side in those World Cups and geez they
are an emerging base man like we talk
about big packs geez they're as big as
they come they are lover scrum love some
set piece stuff and I mentioned some nut
truckers before they just roll up the
sleeves and they just go straight they
don't change direction for anyone so
definitely keep an eye out for them I
think maybe this World Cup's maybe four
years too soon in terms of getting out
of their pool but they will push people
I still I think Fiji beat Wales first up
so we'll start there I do think maybe
they drop a game though to Aussie or
geez I wouldn't be surprised if they
lost to Georgia just as a typical type
of loss to them but oh yeah I'm going
Wales and Fiji to get out why not yeah
fair enough I'm gonna go Fiji to top the
pool I think they will
um like you say I wouldn't be overly
surprised if they lost to a Georgia
um yeah Georgia heavy pack
um very different game style they could
also Fiji could also completely Blitz
him away with some magical tries but um
could be a lot closer than people are
probably expecting
um but I do think Australia will
progress I've seen just enough in the
game I've seen more in their game than
Wales and I think they will go through
but yeah tough pull again these same so
no whales yeah no whales no whales for
me but yeah such small margins obviously
in any rugby game but these big
International games
um such small margins obviously decide
these games and just side the World Cup
so when the teams are so even like these
pools are
um it's only going to be a small margin
that will decide whether they progress
to the finals or not
and we will go to pool D England Japan
Argentina Samoa and Chile so Japan were
ranked obviously the second best team in
the pool
um I think they are now the fourth ahead
of Chile which I I don't to be fair I
don't know much about the Chile
International Rugby side either you know
many of their 20s boys as well nah I've
been watching their 20s mate I'm not
that much of a code Pig obviously love
my footy but you'd have to go on some
pretty Rogue streaming sites to find the
Chilean under 20s I think but it's great
to see them in the World Cup yeah that's
just an achievement in itself and we
need teams like this coming up and
playing like if we want to be a truly
Global game which we always talk about
then I'm all for it yeah great stuff
massive and hopefully all the Chilean
fans are tuning in to the previous show
and um
throughout the tournament we can start
giving you a little bit more insight
into the into your National side oh it
would be a huge nod to be the number one
rugby pod in Chile like I'm all about
that so whatever we need to do to make
it happen let's let's pull some strings
mate yeah okay new goals it's a number
one rugby pod and chili okay let's see
where we get to okay who's who's
progressing I think Argentina beat
England first up I'm confident about
that one they get the one there
then England versus Samoa that last game
decides who goes through I think England
probably get through but just and it's
going to be incredibly tight would love
to see some more but yeah I'm putting my
using my head I'm gonna go Argentina
topper England second yeah I like that
and I can't argue my heart obviously
says Argentina and Samoa Samoa top the
pool
um Argentina just qualified but
um realistically although England have
been disappointing you look at this
squad and you're like how are these guys
struggling like they have a really
strong Squad they got some quality
players
um they've got a massive player pool to
choose from they've got depth everywhere
but
um they just haven't got their game
going at all surely they find something
but
um also wouldn't be gutted if they don't
yeah oh likewise I think Farrell coming
back for kind of those that last pool
game will get them over the line but
yeah I think Argentina beat them first
up for sure and then geez the English
press will be going hard for them they
have to get out of this pool where else
it's going to be chaos because this is
considered pretty much a home or very
close to a home World Cup for them
they're just a stone's throw away so if
they don't make it out of pool play
chaos yeah there'll be a lot of English
fans over there too winding them home so
so you're right about that it will be
have that sort of home feel about it but
no doubt you'll be cheering for Hoover
is playing against them yeah I'm
actually half English hopefully my mum's
not listening to us but the other side I
do not like any sport so yeah there we
go mate we've turned on I I've never
used the passport so I I don't claim it
you know it's just them in my jeans but
not in my heart okay so our predictions
is New Zealand France qualify South
Africa Ireland
Fiji Australia and you've gone Wales and
England Argentina they're the ones
they're the ones qualifying so we'll get
to the quarterfinals as we get a little
bit closer but
um what's your biggest uh concern about
the Rugby World Cup what's something
that's on your mind potentially what's
going to stop this rugby workout from
being the best ever yeah I think it is
going to be this whole refereeing thing
hopefully it's like a case of what we
see in rugby in the past where come the
big games the referees kind of put the
whistle away and they don't make some of
the decisions they do but I think it is
going to be the refereeing the tmos like
some of these shots that we see it is
contact to the head and like by the rule
book yeah sure guides get suspended but
a lot of the times when you're thinking
with common sense and as someone that's
played the game at that level you'd
probably know more than me but a lot of
it like there's no intent there so I
hope they start making these decisions
with that in mind but you just have the
feeling it's going to be something that
happens off the field a suspension or
yeah not player related it's going to be
someone with the whistle or a TMO I
really hope I'm wrong though yeah me too
I think the biggest one for me is that
TMR involvement I felt like previously
there has been like way too much of him
jumping in like I was saying before how
he's checking everything even though the
ref had no issue with the try the tmo's
checking everything just to make sure
basically to see if he can find
something or find a reason why not to
give the give the try sir I I don't like
that in the game and I thought they
found the balance really well in Super
Rugby where they'd only go up if the
referee suspected something so he'd tell
the TMO to check if he felt something
wasn't quite right or try or Foul Play
but when the TMO is checking everything
the whole the whole game he's going to
find all sorts of head collisions all
sorts of mistakes which have cost tries
so you just lose that flow so that's the
big one for me hopefully the TMO can
stay as less involved as possible
he ought almost rather cop a couple
wrong decisions and just have the game
Flow rather than it just be stopped like
obviously referees they do their best
they're only human they make mistakes
like the players do so I'd rather cop
like a missed small knock on at the base
of Iraq or something that a triceline
scored four phases later like they're
still good enough to score the try so
I'd rather that than 62 minutes to play
40 minutes of code 100 and I think that
South Africa game was a perfect example
with the Moody try and the will Jordan
try two two pretty special tries pretty
special moments in the game but both
disallowed because the TMO has gone back
um found a guy a meter offside and a
pretty loose Rock and Mark to less minor
knock on which no one else even noticed
till the TMO scanning the footage so
yeah I'm with you just award the try if
the rift's unsure then he can send it
upstairs but hopefully the TMO stays out
of it what about what is the most
exciting part of the Rugby World Cup for
you
oh I just think how close this is gonna
be like we've already pondered over
these games and and what's gonna happen
and who's gonna get out of pool play
when you look at at least three of the
four pools you can come up with
different scenarios for all sorts of
people getting out and like you said
before it's probably a good side of
doing the draw so far out is that pool
play is a whole lot more exciting than
what it used to be in the past so
obviously you've got these five teams in
each pole pull play takes quite a while
so yeah it's good to have some spice in
these games I I think it's going to be
the closest one going in ever yeah I
agree I feel like there's way more teams
that can win it than you usually go into
a Rugby World Cup and there's no real
obvious favorite I I think the bookies
have the all blacks's favorite still
which is yeah pretty surprising for me
um but obviously who else who else is it
there's like so many teams that could
win it yeah I think if in doubt you just
follow your heart right so I think
there's a fair out of that going on and
a lot of people convincing ourselves but
look like like you said us France Island
South Africa probably there's on their
day that the results can differ so
greatly so it's incredibly exciting as a
fan and that's what you want going on
you want that pressure that nervousness
who's gonna win this game how's it going
to play out and all of a sudden you find
yourself watching games you probably
normally wouldn't watch because every
result is a big factor in the outcome
yeah 100 I think the other thing to add
into that is the fans the French fans uh
a crew that do it differently they get
in behind I can't believe you're going
to be a part of it so jealous for you
but I'm stoked you could do that trip
for what a lad um massive lab but you're
going to be in the mixer singing these
songs waving the flags whistling and
unreal
yeah I've actually um sent that invoice
through with the costs for the travel it
hasn't been um run through your
accountant yet I don't believe but yeah
at this stage I'm still going ripping a
lot of land but yeah well hopefully that
one comes through shortly surely get the
counted onto that ASAP
okay another prediction I want from your
player of the tournament who's going to
be the player of the tournament at the
end of the comp yeah that's rattled me
because it just depends who wins it I
think and you could go in all sorts of
directions obviously the first fives of
the star teams are right up there as
your nominations
um France Dupont the nine obviously one
I thought was a bit of a smoky just if
South Africa can go all the way as
Khaleesi just because he has the story
he has the leadership he's loved by
everyone and how he came back from an
ACL that quickly to be playing rugby the
way he is is phenomenal so I wouldn't
mind that if South Africa were to win
the World Cup say but hopefully it's an
all black and maybe I'll make Richie
Richie Moe he's won the LED seal award
two years in a row with at Super level
can he do it on the big stage and
potentially his last all black game
um is that a scoop is it or he's off to
Japan for three years so yeah unless
they change these rules
um it will potentially be his last all
that game so hopefully not because I
feel like he's still got so much more to
give in the all black Jersey but
um oh it would be good to see him head
off to Japan with the player of the
tournament middle around his neck
because man the kid can play and love to
see him have an awesome tournament but
like you say if France win it I'm pretty
confident player of the tournament will
be Dupont he's just so good but now on
the wing love watching Pino play but
obviously a little bit less involved
um island of Ireland when I'm pretty
sure it's going to be Sexton as well
that guy he runs the cutter for them he
massive influence on their side South
Africa I put down one of the forwards so
um I don't can't really put my finger on
the South African play of the tournament
but I don't mind that shout of Khaleesi
um what a story that would be but
they've got so many massive men in that
pack that they could probably choose
from whoever plays well in that pack I
think will win it and in the All Blacks
mawanga
um yeah I like that chat shout wool
Jordan I think it's gonna be banned for
a baguette Arty's always a great shout
as well scooter Barrett was playing some
of the best footage you'll see from
someone in a rugby Jersey for a long
time obviously the um red card in the
weekend wasn't ideal but he'll make up
for that throughout this competition I'm
pretty sure and
um so many guys to choose from and
they're all black Jersey so we'll we'll
land on mawang all right yeah why not
why not he like he said he's got the
medals in the cabinet already he's
probably running out of room in his
Christchurch estate he might have to
upgrade the trophy cabinet but yeah a
couple lad cells and then a player of
the World Cup
I just live across the road from him so
I see his garage and it looks like it is
overflowing with trophies so yeah well I
heard you did the land seal presentation
out on the driveway the whole Community
came out sausage sizzles The Works mate
it sounds like a heck of a day oh it's a
special Community here down in Marshland
so they all got behind um the marshlands
mirror they call them and
um it was it was a special day to
present him that twice in a row so I
want to go yeah awesome if he could win
it at the World Cup level as well and
one more prediction I want problem yeah
before we finish just a bold prediction
something that's gonna happen that no
one else is really expecting sort of
like a beaver story or
um could be anything could be just a
prediction of one of the teams making it
further than we expect yeah any bold
predictions from the man who knows sport
more than anyone else [__] I don't
really have a beaver like maybe RTS
under the sticks I was just seeing it
three years
that would be massive one of that
Warrior shorts on but an all blacks
Jersey and he dots down to win the World
Cup right how many injuries would they
have to be for RTS to be playing in the
final you reckon oh I think they've put
a line through him a long time ago
unfortunately he's playing good code for
Auckland though isn't he at the back so
now that would be great I think just or
we'll touch on it a couple of times I
think Aussie don't make it out and Eddie
Jones might self-empload they could be
tough they look sharp off the field if
you've seen their get up the old suits
and the hats yeah very sharp I do like
it suits them they've done well there
and I feel like they've done a lot of
really cool stuff off the field um
promoted the game really well they've
used Eddie well for promotion he just
hasn't unfortunately backed it up with
any results I it's almost spent too much
time doing ads and winding up the media
and stuff um as a journalist geez it
would be good for time to go to one of
his press conference wouldn't it just to
ask a few dumb questions and wind them
right up oh big time I feel like you
just got to say like hey Eddie and he'll
just explode it yeah it would make a
heck of a Netflix doco too if somehow
they found a way to win any would be a
great main character he's the villain
and everyone's just coming at him but
that one where he told people to
uppercut themselves I feel like the
questions weren't even that bad and he
just went off his rocker so I want to
see Aussie not make it out that would be
my best possible outcome I'd love to see
someone beat England but I think the
Aussie one's a little more likely how
about yourself what's your Bowl
prediction have you got a white bait
maybe shooter no I might I do have a
semi white bait sort of story and my
prediction is Ethan Blackadder to start
at the in the Rugby World Cup playoffs
he was back for Tasman in the weekend
played a big 40 minutes if he can just
get his body right for the next couple
weeks and he's back
um fully fit I would be surprised if
they don't try and get them over there
at the flick of that next injury here's
the next cab off the rack and I could
imagine him playing a big part in the
playoffs when we need him so there's my
big bold prediction but when you're
speaking about Eddie Jones I was almost
thinking can I wonder if I can get you a
water lad press pass so you can go to
the press conferences and maybe ask him
a few dumb questions see how good would
that be oh man I'm all for it I'll ask
we could get the last notes to put
forward the questions they can be as
ridiculous as people want and I will
happily do it if you can make that press
fast happen because I assume that's a
ticket to every game as well then you've
got yourself a deal but I rate that
blackout of cool too because we are a
little short in those positions he can
cover so I don't mind that and maybe
even we see a moody over there I don't
know how bad lomax's injury is but yeah
I think Lomax is all right 30 stitches
in his leg so it was obviously a massive
gash I don't think I'll be be playing
the first game but it obviously won't
roll them out for the whole world cup
and yeah I'll be up for six years I
reckon yeah geez even to put plaster on
I'm out so 30 stitches that must have
been a massive cash but
um I'm glad that he's okay because it
would have been a disaster to not get to
go to the World Cup he's been playing so
well and he's a good man himself so I do
think Moody will be potentially over
there at some point too as well maybe
not start as much as Ethan blackout in
the Rugby World Cup playoffs but
um yeah I think he'll play A Part put it
here first this is good can't wait for
that press conference with Eddie as well
I have to take some boxing gloves oh
it's going to be good stuff hopefully we
can make that happen but mate appreciate
you coming on um the first Rugby World
Cup preview show
um yeah got it for the next I don't know
how many weeks it is but probably six or
eight weeks
um we'll be bringing you our predictions
to the to the games and surely is
obviously going to give us an insight to
what it's like over there in France and
and then what it's like at the Warriors
Grand final two it's going to be oh what
a what a few months ahead yeah it's
gonna be uh tough on the bank balance
but great for the heart you know and all
blacks and a Warriors when come back to
Queen Street parade the airport will be
going crazy I'll have two black eyes
from Eddie Jones it's gonna be a great
couple of weeks yeah just flick those
invoices through and it shouldn't cost
you too much
yeah somehow I don't think they're
getting covered but yeah look hey you
never know you never know you never know
appreciate it mate we jump now since
recording this episode we found out that
there is a fantasy rugby for the Rugby
World Cup this year super excited about
that it's such a good way to have a
little bit of extra interest in a game
and banter with your mates and what me
and surely are gonna do going forward is
or next weekend we'll give you a full
rundown of our teams our fantasy teams
and we'll give you some tips and having
what we think the best team is possible
and if you are playing make sure you
join the waterlad League there is a link
on the Woodland Instagram page so go
check that out and make sure you get
involved in that one it's about 50
people in there ready and hopefully we
grow that to at least over a couple of
hundred before it starts and have a bit
of fun hopefully be able to give some
prizes away to the winners too also it
is Father's Day on Sunday so if you're
unsure on what to get your old man get
him a water lead tea make sure you go on
waterlair.com right now order it so that
he can have that before Sunday the black
on black one also doubles down as a
great all black supporters top so it's a
win-win so head over to woodland.com and
go get amongst it
absolutely
[Applause]
[Music]